What we have just done here, is a very powerful idea in learning.
Convergence is important. Because without convergence, a learning agent could
zig zag forever in a large learning space. We want to ensure that the learning
agent converges to some concept characterization, and that remains stable.
This method guarantees convergence, as long as there is a sufficiently large
number of examples. We needed five examples in this particular illustration, for
the convergence to occur. This convergence would have occurred, irrespective of
the order of the examples, as long as the five examples were there. Note that we
did not use background knowledge like we did in incremental concept learning.
Note also that we did not assume that the teacher was forwarding the examples in
the right order. This is the benefit of version space learning. There is
another feature to note. In incremental concept learning, we wanted each example
different from the current concept characterization in exactly one feature, so
that the learning agent could focus its attention. However inversion spaces,
you can notice that each successful example, the first one,
the previous one and many features, just look at the first two examples.
They differ in many features in the name of the restaurant, in the meal,
in the cost. Here is the algorithm for the version space technique.
We'll go through it very quickly, because we've already illustrated it in
detail. If the new example is positive, generalize all specific models included.
Prune away the general models that cannot include the positive example.
If the example is negative, specialize all the general models to include it.
Prune away the specific models that cannot include the negative example.
Prune away any models subsumed by the other models. Know that in this
specific implementation of version space technique that we just illustrated,
there is a single pathway coming from the most specialize concert model.
And therefore there is no need to prune away specific models. In general,
there could be multiple generalizations coming for
the most specialized models, and this might be needed.